we're chatting with mr. Gregory bein
online today he's the filmmaker from
person of interest from from Jen's
Pulver driven and now his latest project
Bloodsworth he's in production on and
Gregory were just wanted we want to
thank you you know we know you have a
lot going i want to thank you for
chatting with us and really um you know
we just released goodbye promised online
today it's a very ambitious endeavor so
we're just going to chat with you about
it we're going to chat with you about
maybe some things you've learned because
you've also done some unconventional you
know like um you know creating your own
path in terms of distribution your
thoughts on your own you know just doing
it your own way and find I success that
way and you've also done things that you
know more more traditionally as well so
you've kind of and so I don't know we
just want to hear from you a little bit
pick your brain and learn from someone
we really respect oh it's kind of you um
congrats by the way that's really cool i
love what you're doing I mean it looks I
you'd been sort of leading up to it and
I really had no idea kind of checking in
but I know what you're going to pull out
a hat and I was surprised actually and I
thought it's actually a very cool and
interesting know where they new approach
so yeah yeah no I mean we hope so you
know it just this is something that
that's literally been on our mind for
you know since last August last last
last August September is um you know I
mean obviously we thought we'd finish
goodbye promise much sooner than this
and it's just one of this been one of
these films are just sort of drag doings
dragged out it's just like everything
else could I think like that everything
that could go wrong has gone wrong you
know in the post-production process so
it's you know we were always well we
start like okay we're going to release
it now and it just that they never came
and so I guess it's given us more time
to think about you know doing something
like this and then even with all the
thinking that goes into it at the end of
the day you still just have to put it
out there and just roll up the sleeves
and put in the hustle uh yeah well I'm
going to thinking you never know exactly
how I was going to go obviously and it
can be you know i'm going to may
surprise you it may try
great ways or mr. president is pointing
ways to know but it's all sir idiot I
mean for me over the last couple years
the one thing that I just continually
hammer home in my head in my work is
that it really just is about getting it
out and being as prolific as possible
and sometimes it's easier than others
yeah I've been working on Bloodsworth
actually I've been working on
Bloodsworth now since it's been over a
year i'm almost a year and a half
probably observed between developing and
shooting and shooting and belt painted
and it's been you know i feel like i'm
still at the very beginning of making
the movie and it's for you know
frustrating that way but it was been
nice to there's some things that have
gotten out there but I'm realizing the
key is just like to keep getting work
out there and to find new and
interesting ways to do that I think that
you guys have done that with this you
know i mean it will i said it was sort
of surprised that guy i'd never thought
of trying that and i think I mean the
great thing is the other thing that I
realize is that it's hard to like if
somebody does something really cool it's
really successful at it you can sort of
glean some things from it we can't
really repeat it it's very difficult to
do that because there's like it's like
the film itself it takes all these sort
of things you know come together whether
their people and tightening and you know
whatever the universe brings together to
make that thing happen and then actually
be something and it's that way with the
distribution you know I mean like person
of interest we put it out on bodo exert
orange for free and I think you know I
mean according to the ticker on photo
it's like been downloaded I think just
shy 400,000 times but I think I don't
know that that's an accurate ticker but
then one of the people to download it it
put it up on YouTube and you know it's
been washed almost half a million times
on YouTube and there's quite a
discussion going but it's also a thing
where I mean look at the guy didn't go
to ads on so he's not making money I he
just
like to put it up so I was happy about
that but um yeah I had thought about
three it out that way and maybe try and
make money off the ads or something but
it's actually more interesting because
just it's just out there and people are
watching it and there's a lot of
discussion I mean especially for that
movie because it's about you know Iraq
war vet there's actually a lot of war
vets dealing with PTSD that are really
seeming to connect with the film um but
again it's just out there and has all
you do really it's just out and then
driven obviously visible more
conventional and it's been it's been
good it's been fruitful I mean it's nice
like I have a film that's making money
by making you know like ridiculous I'm
not suddenly independently wealthy or
anything but yeah it's pretty nice i get
a check every quarter and I cut that in
half I give half of its gems and they
take my half and you know I've been able
to you know to actually been nice to
know like well the end of that month
there will be checked I have no idea 10
before I mean some of the amounts I know
what they'll be like there's licensing
agreements with like Netflix which is a
flat fee but then there's you know how
many people are going to be downloading
and washing on iTunes or Amazon or now
if it's on hulu there's a chair you know
and that was we just got some of that it
wasn't not remarkable at this point but
I'm not completely I'm it makes me want
to investigate like how does that work
and how do I get more people watching it
there is that your what percentage of
the ads whoops end if you who plus I
think those things I'm trying to
understand all that the nice thing is
I've seen that it's actually been even
though it's been released on netflix has
been released and been washed a lot
there I have noticed that the revenue in
terms of people buying it online from
like itunes is not really ticked down
it's been pretty consistent so that's
been nice but I right now I'm just
rambling on doing questions for me oh
yeah do you want to start one any
questions criminally ok I'm just I'm
taking it all in on my okay
but no I like what you say to about you
know people who sort of are the first
ones to establish a way of doing
something it makes me think of em four
eyed monsters no and how they were very
successful with their film and just you
know just incorporating the video
responses from the viewers and things
like that and then it's it's a little
hard to duplicate because it's already
been done it was such a you know sort of
a rare gem yeah that's exactly I mean
there's all those things but it's great
because they're also like what they did
in that project I think opened up
people's mind to the experiential things
you can create around your project now I
mean I know a lot of people talk about
transmedia and all that and I think
there's a level of that but it's more
about just taking and like not leaving
any meat on the bone in terms of your
footage and stuff and really creating an
event and they created a really
interesting thing and then again like
rather getting a video podcasting a
lesser stuff so again it was all those
strange factors that came together and
perfect timing and and yeah there's a
lot to glean from it but even you know
with you like Aaron crumbly it so it's
not something sustainable you can't do
that again that's you have to then what
it really comes back to and I think that
a lot of people forget this is that you
have to have a high quality for gifted
craft and as I you know I've been saying
I've talked to a couple you know like
panels not sort of thing the recent year
my mo is that you know that sort of
transaction you know we always think
well we make a movie and then somebody
pays us to watch it and that's that's
how we make our money that's the
transaction and I think that that is
well it's not accurate anymore one and
our art way you know the the our
monetary gain from our work is not a
straight woman anymore it's we may do
this driven may make a little bit of
money it may lead to something else or
may not
but I have that out there and but then
somebody saw that this actually happened
to me so somebody's not driven they
didn't end up doing it just because of
money it was a Southern California
project but somebody's had driven on
netflix and then I'm easily accessible
on the web so he contacted me to direct
a documentary for them unfortunately it
was timing and me being the night at the
time it was being Sean Southern
California with didn't really work out
but you know it's an example of like
it's not a straight line but well
there's people and things out there
happening that you don't really realize
and one way or another if you're
prolific enough and your craft just good
enough and your your work is continuous
on people do notice and start to pay
attention and you know maybe it may not
be a film that may not be a documentary
it may be you know i mean like Aaron
chrome way since we're on him I mean he
did that thing with google nexus you
know i'm sure he got paid a pretty penny
to do some work with google you gotta do
something in his style and make
something cool and get paid and that's
how it works now it's well you know the
tentacles are why not there you just
have to you know be willing i think to
not say i think hard in this day and age
people that I think you know that are
our level of the industry which yeah i
think is is it used to be like the real
low wrong if indeed but you know the
this all the scaffolding at above us is
sort of falling down and I think
everybody's like charred because they're
looking around good on the sand well
with you people but I think it's it it's
the way it is you know we're all sort of
on the same field and some people that
are doing great work and being poetic
and being accessible and be nice I think
that there's a lot of opportunity to
find a lot of different gigs I mean if
you look around at most people that are
you can do anything like I'm doing they
may be doing a little more successfully
granted but you know they're directing
episodes TV shows or doing short
commercial sponsor and doing this of
doing that you know to pay the bills
along the way
I think that's just the way it's coming
every once in a while you might have a
nice little hit and be able to generate
some income from you know your actual
work that's yours the UM which is great
and the other part of tuna is that you
can yell like I on with Jason my own
person of interest and I on with Jen's I
even driven in with Bloodsworth I don't
know with Kirk you know it's so this is
very limited you know and the between me
and the money there's you know there's
nothing there's no middle man there's
nobody you know and that's figuring out
the financing either you're doing it for
a little bit of money that you can just
put on your own or you're doing it for
somebody like I raised for driven more
like I'm raising for Bloodsworth which
is you know it's also in kick start with
the majority but we'll probably end up
being like grants and foundational money
you know trying to limit the upfront
costs or limit any cost that's going to
have to go back to investors is also key
found in Seoul distribution matrix so
making it work and make any make money
and give any opportunity like you have
to do things that people aren't doing
and being able to experience because no
matter like if the thing goes
gangbusters and you make a bunch of
money this month that'll be great and
everyone will applaud you be very happy
for you if it does moderately well and
you gain a whole new fresh audience
because you've basically said hey here's
our work watch it please and you know
and literally we're asking for any
almost a favor like it should have
bought pitch into box yeah but nobody is
going to go you know how I'm
gonna but I kind of think of very I
think that you give you a selfie
opportunity like you already have
because you've already been very active
in the community obviously given such
great going voice to the independent
community but also you introduced a lot
you have some great interviews and give
you that a lot of educational stuff
going on that people really appreciate
it so you have all these things bundled
together so I don't be in arsenal next
30 days go for it I hope forget things
this is so cool to sit down and connect
with you
Gregory you know and just sort of
connect with you off the cuff you know
III didn't want to I want to come back
to person of interests and Votto you
know because um you know that that was
you sort of experimenting with getting
you're getting that work out there and
it's really interesting to hear you say
that it's gotten you know maybe a
hundred thousand downloads but then
someone took it and off shoot it to you
two were then that announcement seen
half a million times on it and I know I
know like when it started blowing up on
youtube I know we emailed you or contact
you said hey you know have you have you
notified that guy to just like put a
link to the DVD I mean did he ever do
that that he ever like link kk he did he
put the link to the website on there I
didn't know my back and done yes
interesting how about Scott because I
didn't you know I looked at one point I
I saw it go up at the initial because I
always get like Google alerts and if I
saw that was me oh that's how I email
the guy I said hey I'm glad you like the
movie thanks for uploading that you know
I mean I was there for you to share so
saw like I didn't go can't you did that
and I remember I saw it like around like
december or something and i saw that it
had like thirty eight thousand views i
was like rounds it's pretty good and
then i think four months laters 220,000
i was like what will happen here this is
there's always discussion i mean some of
it was granted like YouTube discussion
which is I said I don't completely
understand it's funny though because
it's a part of me that's really glad
that somebody else uploaded because then
I'll have to have the commentary rolling
sort of on my feed and I cuz I always
feel compelled that I have to respond to
people and I don't I there's a lot I
don't want to respond to their but
there's been some pretty incredible
comments as well so it's an interesting
thing I mean I it's really you talking
about one thing leading to another is
that like that whole situation with
person of interest I was talking to my
friend Cory MacCabe here did american
astronaut and stingrays and I've loved
his work when
at in 2010 we were talking to the same
the same conference in New York and I
just been a huge fan so I was like I for
me I get starstruck about people I can
because I play you make such amazing
cool stuff I wish I you know like had
Alice of your talent so amazing so he
became fast friends and he'd been going
through like he made his films were more
conventionally sort of and had just come
off doing this he has a film out now
called crazing team which is really
pretty low budget he and a friend went
shot of his kids it's fantastic I
absolutely loved the movie but um back
last this March we were talking the
phone he's like I you know bunch about
that crowd sourcing stuff yeah I mean I
guess you know it's like well I'm just
saying I have this idea and I want to
you know I'm trying to figure out how to
do this thing and um we so we created
that we've started this group called
with captain Ahab's motorcycle club
which is this sort of completely
embracing the idea of the internet and
all of it are bringing so if you like up
till now especially in the film and
definitely music and other things
artists have not been able to in some
ways rightfully so get over that
threshold where they may be like free
sharing of all this is good thing and
getting back to just sheer creativity is
a great thing you know and we looked at
some different things like that Joseph
gordon-levitt's you know hit record com
he already does like this a bunch of
people and they may use tidbits of
things and then if they make money they
give you money we're like we're not that
guy and we can't create anything like
that we just want to create like this
sort of global experience where we make
something cool so having gone through
person of interest and these ideas of
sharing you know how it can actually be
beneficial maybe you don't know when
you're going to reap the rewards from
any of this which is I think really hard
for a lot of people and in all
fairness like it wasn't a movie that
cost me a half a million dollars so I
don't have a bunch of money how to pay
somebody back which if I did then maybe
some of the things I've done would be
irresponsible but under the you know
it's a 500lb spell it's not but yo so
this idea of being able to start to
really embrace the free-flowing nature
of the internet that we can create
things we can figure out how maybe not
to monetize the product like the thing
with Captain Ahab is that you Corey like
uploaded a bunch of music tracks of the
zoning we send Molly please download
them you can perform them you can remix
them you just can't sell them you know
and please share them back with us I
mean share with greater community we're
doing the same thing with art and with
eventually what we're going to do is
make a film which corrine i'll raise the
financing for the portion that we're
doing which will be the spine of this
movie and there were hoping we got
chapters in Brazil UK Ireland and
Iceland them you know Russia I mean all
these people are starting to get into
this big idea like I will create
something together and the little idea
is that you know individually people
will be you know raising their own
little bits of money to make their
pieces of the project and then Corey
will direct this film from this wide
tapestry that we have and I'll produce
it and then we'll release it for free
and that's the process and it's not
necessarily about financial gain and
it's definitely adhering to the ideal
well our transaction for this for our
any any of the artists financial benefit
is not going to be a direct I make this
people pay me for it it's going to be we
all embark on a shared endeavor we make
something really cool put it out for the
world to experience and you know
whatever benefit we glean from whoever
season oh great so anyway that's that's
long you don't want a minute how great
is that I mean this is a guy because we
know that you know you've really
respected Corey mcafee and this must be
a dream come true like you know that
this project
that refer it's it's super various it's
incredibly cool you know now also to to
be involved in you know I mean this and
they were talking about to some more
traditional products or products
projects where you know i'll hopefully
help them produce you know the next
feature beyond this one and that's great
so yeah it's that to me it really starts
to become more i think that you guys are
definitely evidence of this it's about
you know even they say be the change you
want to see in the rule is nicole make
the art you want to see in the world you
know I really didn't art is my solace
that makes me happy I am seeing great
are being part of grade are being
created you know stuff that I'm into I
hopefully that's the thing so yeah I
mean definitely being able to work the
quarry who's a great person um a good
friend now and I I feel like we're doing
something that we both genuinely want to
do from a truly like we want to figure
out how to make something like this work
successfully there's so many pitfalls to
it inherently with shared collaboration
trying to take out as many of those as
we can we know it's going to be a big
effort eventually but we knew the first
one was the moneys or like they take
that on equation right out of game the
money has got to be like there is no way
if it makes any or generates any money
if we give it to charity that's that's
how we roll so I like what you said
earlier to you touched on sometimes it's
not the project that you think is going
to be sort of the big hit or make all
the money its people seeing that and
then something other coming out of that
and that is something that I don't know
if you've ever read or listen to hugh
macleod he wrote ignore everybody 39
keys to creativity and so II I've heard
of that but I don't think I present yeah
it's not about reading books on
creativity but it's an i have it on
audio
and I listen to it while I'm driving and
Zhang so yeah he just talks about a lot
of times it's not the thing that you
think is going to launch a career at
something ancillary something that
that's a side thing that comes out of it
almost reminds me of Anthony Bourdain of
kitchen confidential and if I heard him
correctly I think he makes most of his
living speaking and it wasn't actually
from the book or the show but I could be
mistaken on that but yeah you just don't
know what someone's going to see out
there and and and how it could take a
new route for you yeah and I think
that's where it comes in you gonna be
open I mean will perhaps your career
lead to that point where you take over
the Batman series from Christopher Nolan
maybe probably not but you know just
because you know you know I'm obviously
there's a studio system in that
trajectory which I I don't understand it
all I minute live in idaho most of the
time and that I'm in New York so I'm
like far far away from Los Angeles and I
really don't understand any of that i
Donna and I don't claim to or have any
sort of you know illusions to this that
I have keyed in on how any of that would
work but I do know that just generally
that you know if you want to be a
creative person anyone work and make a
living from that you can do that it just
requires a lot of hustle and it requires
being open to doing a lot of things that
you think maybe that you wouldn't have
done and you know not in a bad way I'm
not doing porn so there's that you know
you know what was I love hearing you say
that you know cuz we know honestly I
mean you know Karen I we've spoken to so
many filmmakers who had sort of these
horrific experiences with distributors
you know they take their work and it can
be a treacherous thing you know because
you're getting into business I mean you
know with with people you don't
necessary Rome and you're entrusting
them that they're going to get it out on
the right place
forms on get it out you know help you
get out to the audience market it and
then at the end of the day return money
you know and we often hear that you know
more and more there's no money up front
for filmmakers and then at the same time
you hear there's not really money in the
back end but you're saying checks are
coming in every month so can you talk a
little bit about that and you talk about
how long did it take to get to the point
where all of a sudden checks were coming
so too so gravitas ventures is who is
releasing driven and the deal I have
with them and I don't know how they
structure all the deals I think they're
all probably pretty close to this and so
it's a pretty fair deal is that you know
I I paid for the delivery which was for
VOD which is about fifty four hundred
dollars for do you know the like HD
mastery and everything you have to be a
closed captioning that sort of thing and
then there was another around three
thousand dollars for you know insurance
so you know 50-54 excuse me eighty-four
dollars you know it's just a big chunk
of money but also like the film's new
basically but they they have a deal with
Warner Brothers where Warner Brothers
digital put it out through their VOD
networks so yeah what they described to
me initially was we can get it out to
about 12 15 million households on her
own their own video on demand like cable
VOD and then there's then they do also
like iTunes and all the Internet
platforms but then there's warner
brothers who can expand it to 100
million homes and then luckily we got
into that track which was very cool and
so basically the billing works is that
it released in july and i didn't see a
check until january because you
basically have like the internet
distributors so they they're on a
monthly sort of thing so say somebody
rinse in july their build their and then
make pain august total but then Warner
Brothers has 120 days to pay
gravitas it makes me the VOD it works
you know so somebody rinse it in July
they pay it on their August bill and
then in August the VOD cable company
pays born brothers in September and then
there's the turnaround and I you pay ya
it was the slaw it was a about nine
months before seeing actual return um
but I was I was actually surprised i
actually wasn't expecting to see
anything until March of this year but I
got checked the end of January I was
like yeah I mean it wasn't earth
shattering but you know it was in the
thousands and I was like oh great and
then and then you know the next one went
up the next one went a little bit down
but not so ridiculous and you know they
kind of gave me a range where it might
fall in the first year and it's it's
pretty on track for that it's on the
lower end but again I'm not so that you
know there's a lot of films out there's
a lot of competition and and driven I
mean luckily Jen's is a lot of name no
notoriety and I think it's kept it going
that plus I think films actually quite
good which helps to keep it going it
really is thank you but you know so it
has stayed like I said you know the the
the VOD was for a window so it basically
released July first ish I can't remember
the exact date but released in July and
then for six months so basically july
through december it was on only on paid
platforms and the cable video on demand
stuff they all cycle through so i don't
there's a lot of cable networks it's
probably not on anymore it's mostly
online now oh I said the the internet
stuff seems to be fairly consistent
again it's not worth shattering numbers
but frankly I feel like any independent
film
any numbers of better profit you know at
this point is pure profit it films paid
off all anybody it's all taken care of
and now basically the checks come in
with my side of X we keep a little back
and then we just we split it and going
our merry way and it's great because the
gems is getting direct benefit from the
film bears his name it's a good scenario
and there are other things that we
probably will continue to do with in the
future the great thing is to is I
basically have only licensed to them to
them so they have just video on demand
for three years and the end of that we
can renegotiate it or all the rights go
back to me here however we do that and
it's also a good thing because you never
know like 3am in 2014 where are things
going to be in terms of video in demand
hopefully they'll still be on an uptake
but there may be a situation where
people like us can do more directly with
some of these platforms mmm I mean was
that was that something you push forward
did you push for the license and convert
aning ownership that was there I'm sir
there that's kind of their blanket deal
like that who I mean the problem is that
I mean most of these companies like they
they understand i think that you know
whenever we're going to films like this
there's good it's going to be there's a
short window of profit really you know i
mean i know it's all talk about the long
tail i think the long tail eventually
comes from we own it like i don't i do
all the DVD stuff I've looked into a bit
of DVD distribution I think you know
there's a potential that maybe we could
do in like if I can get into walmart
that would be great but you know the
problem is now which is traditional
distributors because there's not a lot
of money in DVD there there coupling it
with VOD and I wanted the gravitas
because I felt like they had a really
good deal but are split with them is I
give 7570 of 25% for their efforts and
but they don't do DVD some of the
company likes of the do DVD couple of
VOD so because I already have my VOD
deal in place and can't offer them
that's been a little bit of a
problem but you know we sell again
knotted earth-shattering numbers but you
know we have sold DVDs every single
month since you know november two
thousand ten so except for the time why
I took it off this is why I'm like
doesn't really matter what you do a guy
in I have the DVD out I had digital
downloads that cuz i was using topspin i
had everything going october well
november two thousand ten how'd it go in
January's when I met gravitas people by
marsh we had a deal and they're
basically like we haven't had a fishel
release yet well nothing official no and
so okay well you have to take the DVD
off sale like you can the VOD release
stated the DVD released a have to
coincide so I basically took it off the
market from march until july but again
every other single month except for that
period of time or just simply wasn't
available we've sold dvds i just sold
one today so yeah and yeah it's not like
i said it's not astronomically but you
know we sell them for sixty ninety nine
plus shipping handling you know there's
a little bit of fuse ago with amazon or
topspin whichever one they come through
but you know in terms of like if i have
a dvds distributor my margin might be
like I get a block or two forgive me
this this way I mean gems are splitting
like you know fifteen bucks which is a
much higher margin so you know it's a
lot more work I make a lot of tracks
down to the post office but it's great
for losing weight so I you know I mean
do you notice it makes any difference
the thing that mean to do the people
buying the dvds and and you know
supporting direct I mean do you find
that makes a difference like if they
know that the money is going back to you
and the money's going back to jen's I
honestly at this point in time I don't
think so like when we were doing most of
the fundraising that way I mean that's
how i funded movie you know it was
basically the Kickstarter and then pre
selling DVDs
I think then it is and there's also is
that initial edition was a much more
sort of special edition DVD then we have
the fan edition DVD being sold out up
afterwards and then we're on the next
the brother 3rd run of a thousand that
we have done you know so we got rid of
quite a few dvds and I think now it's
just it's it's actually that nice place
you know so this people for words it's
just a movie you know it's just a movie
out there that people go out watch that
movie I want to own that movie so
there's really have anything to you know
I afraid this joint has a lot more to do
gents you know and wanting to see a
movie about him they anything else so
but I like that because it's not it's
join the ranks of movies it's just a
movie and get it watching I'm wondering
what was what's the short window you
said they're sort of this very short
period of time to sort of get those
views and then deliver that it kind of
lingers oh well I guess my point with
that is it it probably doesn't make a
lot of economic sense unless the movie
does incredibly well for these companies
here to try and buy all your rights I
mean one you're going to sell your
rights for zero dollars because those
make a lot of sense so a three-year
window for them to have exclusive
license on certain aspects of your
property makes sense because there's you
know I said that first six months is
probably the initial you know I know for
the first six months there's love you
talk and everything generated obviously
generated most of its video-on-demand
revenue during that period of time we're
going overseas here eventually so I'm
hoping that we'll have another stroke
optic with that but you know epson flow
so I'm just saying that my point was
more towards you know I think
distributors like gravitas and some of
the others in the VOD market or
realizing they have to be a little more
nimble
having this them personally having a
catalog of films the bait own is not
exactly like the studio's you know
that's a big deal but for these
distributors that are basically
providing video-on-demand service deals
for you it doesn't believe them to own
the property it moves them to have
exclusive rights to it for a certain
period of time so they can make the
money most likely the most money that
will be generated for the film in that
platform for that period of time and
have that as opposed to trying to create
a library films I think that that's that
you know the library films now is going
to come down to the individual artists i
think you know it's like i wanna i would
like to own my library of films so then
you know someday where people just
looking for this exclusive thing I'm the
one that has it and they have to come to
me sort of situation but um yeah so I
mean that I think with any film it was
like any it's like box office in general
you see it's like the first three weeks
like just go to you depend on the movie
the Sox it's the first two days and it
goes down but it's just that there is
sort of this window you're going to make
probably bulk of your income I'll say
that there isn't a long tail that you
can't write out I think there is and if
you can continue the success than being
luckily wood trim it I feel like it's a
film that really resonates with people
beyond like I was very specific in
making a film you know it was about the
fight world but not in the way that most
people wanted like the only bad reviews
I've gotten about the film I've been
people that were mad at in make film the
way they wanted to see it which is a
normal biopic with you know interviews
of James's coaches and all this for
thing I made a movie that was about a
guy in a space and time that could
relate you know that if you're you know
a human being you can relate to him you
know it doesn't matter that he does this
thing it's that he is a genuine human
being going through genuine struggles
coming from a genuinely hard place but a
lot of people recognize directly from
their own experience but then even if
you don't share that
Arians you can empathize with them and a
server sympathetics but with his plate
and you know I that's been the biggest
thing is like I feel like this film if I
have made the other film I would have
really short life I would have a lot of
people that were into MMA watch it be
done with it and that was it it wouldn't
have had any crossover honey and send
people that are you know like one of my
friends as a dancer you know loves the
movie she just loves it but you know
would really not be in the mixed martial
arts and Evans so it's thinking about
those things too i know it's about the
long longevity of it but a lot of that
comes to so hard because you can that's
why I it was but it was interesting
because I know like I think that your
show took the uptake sort of like 2010's
2011 there's a lot of conversation about
what you have to do what you need to do
we know and in the problem is that the
lobbyists things now the dust is
starting to settle and it really all
comes back to like I always sorry but
it's just the fundamentals I
fundamentally do good work and work to
get it out there but you can just make
good work and then go up stun them not
do anything with you go to it should
really work at it to get it out there
and to have your voice heard and
hopefully not an annoying way this
nobody likes that but to just you know I
guess I they to be prolific and have a
strong craft and continue to work and
continue to add something so the
community as a whole but in terms of
your work and how will be received
really little control over that no
matter what you do you know it's just
you have to make the work from to the
best of your ability from your own
perspective and experience and and you
know a lot of ways hope for the best can
you plan and strategize certain things
yes will it always go the way you think
it will you hope it will know generally
one but each you know it's all a step
you know I mean two years ago I don't
have a phone out that people can go you
know that's in the top
selling documentaries on itunes now
sporting young sports documentaries this
point I mean a state in the top 200
documentaries period on itunes for seven
months graduations yeah and again it's
like it doesn't really mean much though
it had to be generating revenue which is
helpful um but you know I'm people that
and I saw this a couple years ago I'm
like well just really doing a whole lot
of good to have a movie it and into
movie theaters like that if people are
watching movies they're not these up
anything I'm making people are going to
go online if you want to be illegitimate
filmmaker people you know people always
ask that question oh where can i see
your movie you say well you can see it
in topeka or you can say oh we're just
gonna flick said oh well you're a
filmmaker oh so you know and it's it's
so it's just being where the actions at
really is how I see it you know and who
knows what next platforms are going to
come up but I like things being
accessible and I also pay attention to
what I do you know I was I talk to
filmmakers and you you with like sir
these grand ideas about how their work
should be presented not only okay how do
you watch movies well I go on ethnic sir
idea ran on itunes or something okay
yeah and so does everybody else so high
why don't you look at the you know where
the actions out where people are
actually watching and go there and by
going there and then having a bean
available in those platforms then
eventually I think you can draw back to
your own you know your own site your own
sort of ecosystem space but that just
takes time before people are seeking you
out you know how funny high and weighing
on no no you're making it on this great
information you know I really just have
two more things I like to cover then
we'll let you get back to doing
everything you do Gregory and that you
know in addition anything care may have
for you I'm just curious you know with
person of interest
and with you know Jen's both out there
you know driven you know just highlights
you know think things that you know the
things that you've learned from from
releasing both films you know having
them out there and maybe some takeaways
in terms of how that you know what what
direction that's pointing you as you
maybe start to think of what you're
going to do with loads worth well the
first thing I would say is that I think
people worry about torrenting is stupid
I find the whole argument I the argument
that for my Hollywood I mean grand more
people again letting their stuff but i
don't i honestly would be hard-pressed
than good turning revenue if you're an
independent and you're quoting me
numbers of what you could have made
you're completely insane the other part
of it is is that the reason i did with
personal interest is a guy love Jamie
King I think that he's a smart guy I
like the direction they're going I love
his ideals of Lincoln eliminating
friction but for me I don't torque
because there's so much friction like I
don't know what to do it's just it seems
like such a pain in the ass and I know
that the majority of people is are just
like me as such a pain the apps i can i
find it on netflix or itunes or Hulu or
something easily accessible thing where
I know like I pay bucks and I get a see
stuff that's what people want they don't
want to be you know they're younger
people that are willing to spend a
little bit maybe have a little more
discretionary time to go and do this
thing but like I find it I'm just not
interested in it because I don't it's
too hard you know and so I think that we
gotta stop worrying about that can it
eventually be a tool possibly I think
that yeah I've been watching what has
been successful on bow down especially
together series pioner one genre stuff
I'm actually developing they just got a
grant to do a project that I'm
developing now to shoot right next year
it's a it's a web serial basically um
not like a 10-minute funny thing but
like I'm
engine so it's like actual episode link
24 minute episodes and but totally to
release online and totally for free into
you do something that that is hopefully
I think geared towards the web audience
but but just for 21st century thinking
so that bit about Torrance in terms of
Bloodsworth yeah there's wind driven I
was very bent like I just the only
distribution I'm really interested in
this video on demand because I feel like
that's where people are watching movies
I feel like get it out on these
platforms it'll sort of help provide a
little bit of legitimacy not only for
the film or for myself and that was my
goal with bugs worth you know it's kind
of actually even going a little bit more
towards the traditional round not
necessarily at the Asheville release but
I would like to see it on the festival
film I would like to see it um you know
if if at all possible and I doubt that
it probably is on the small budget that
I have available to me but you never
know I might be able to pull something
out of the hat to be an award winning
film that people like seek out i'm
definitely am interested in via v4 but
i'm also interested in partnering with
organizations like PS and that sort of
group and you again like opening a lot
of different doors that I don't
currently have access to directly you
know I'm starting to gain access again I
mean buzzword is actually interesting
story have people to mentoring me
through PBS and only because I had a 20
year I was 18 minute clip of Kirk
telling a story and it's there's not
much to it it's black and white he's
basically he has a he has a speech that
he did squeeze a public speaker and he
tells the story and it's very compelling
so I filled him doing that because good
i put on youtube and then I got a call
from these people producing a series for
PBS like we want you to do a
a short film for this series on PBS and
I wish to do a thing about Kirk
unfortunately because of the PBS
scheduling budgeting I don't know that
the series going forward but again it's
one of those things where it's not a
direct line all of a sudden all these
new doors open up they don't know exists
only because I wasn't cagey about the
work I just put it out you know this is
what I'm working on this is the guy
telling the story this is why i think
it's compelling anyway i'm getting a
long rambling the answer you you know I
learned a lot of things definitely about
you know I think we're the best places
in terms of VOD how it may be couple
these things together I try to do a tour
with driven the search semi is
successful I want to do that a lot more
successfully with Bloodsworth and I'm
working early to partner with
organizations like the innocence project
and the ECM you so that the film can be
you know a tool that's actionable for
them they can then use for their own
purposes the biggest thing i think i've
learned in all of these is to not be
cagey with the work you know it's a if
you want to you want to own it and you
want to figure out how best to make
revenue off of it because it really is
for me all about sustainability and this
is all this you know plus the other sort
of gigs that i do that's all i do I
don't have a job so sustainability is a
huge key factor for me and like anyone
else I'm child I have a home I want to
grow and you know eventually be or
perhaps for tire or at least you know
feel like I could so but I think that if
you're continuing cagey about the work I
mean osteopathy estate the stage it
feels like you're being cagey about the
word it's probably how very good yeah if
you're willing to get out there and just
hustle with it show it and you know get
in front of people with it and not be
weird about how people watch it you know
because one it
there's so many different viewing
experiences in so many different ways in
which people connect with the you know
and maybe some person you know I know
people of torture driven you know my new
we're in the early is actually I had
some people on some private mmm a
torrent sites they were they had it and
and I just emailed him I said hey would
you you know I I see my movie gents my
illness or vista explain sort of the
scenario like this was there's no
company behind this of us and the acid
they put a description working goodbye
the movie you know I own that actually I
think generated some cells and I I just
think it's about being open and willing
to his room except those incoming
connections as best you can you can't
always you know work with everyone and
every other way that they're sort of
coming at you or respond everyone but I
think if you can be open you do yourself
more service than damage and I know a
lot of people who are you though is
leave that my experience has been that
it's not an even with it being torrented
I think the only reason now it's you
know and I've been noticing some
torrents going on overseas and sites
just because the international release
it's like it's not readily available I
get it yeah so two part question here
with blood sports you plan to make dvds
for I am look at you guys finding i'm
actually i'm now wondering yes DVD is I
think DVDs yes I am actually because I
think DVD is especially the stuff I'm
going to be doing with or hope to be
doing not no deals and sealed but hope
to be doing with Sonia's large
organization so i'm pretty sure the DVD
would be sort of the easiest thing for
them to do but then I'm looking you know
because hunter weeks is not always
awesome blu-rays and I've been so
envious of that there's so damn
expensive but I think with Bloodsworth
there might be a little bit more demand
for that I mean they're kind there is
for driven but it's just such a huge
expense at this point that it's not
really possible but I'm hoping to within
the budget for both over to raise money
from
for both yeah which reminds me of hunter
weeks is 10 miles per hour he put that
on yeah yeah and my other question was
just to further explain your definition
of kg in insulin I'm wondering if some
people are doing things they don't
realize or holding themselves back and
put me in kg well i think you know like
the Dynamo player like I think it's a
cool idea but I think it's kind of
like show eight mins of movie
in and say ok pay me and see the rest hi
people don't do that now go oh yeah I
mean and there are some granted i'm sure
really low-budget independent films that
aren't that good in the first a mess
that you will definitely pay to watch
the rest of it most of my think ill go I
gotta pay to watch their assistant no
I'm but I can just be my guess my
greater definition being cagey with the
word is that you know I find there's a
lot of people the filmmakers that you
know they're so afraid people just steal
from them but it beat the script or
footage or if somebody's going to
torrent the movie yeah i mean i've seen
people go like because of you that if
you have a movie on internet movie
database if your listing there's some
you know pre torrent site there's gonna
be catalog in your title and they're
gonna say this movie is available blah
blah well they're not really there and
i've had people for you how did they get
my movie oh I it's on your computer in
your hard drive only so I don't think
they really have movie and also the
people who are like yeah I read an
article on this year and a half gar
slang but the LA Times you know some guy
explaining how this movie is torn at
this main times you lost 150 thousand
dollars in revenue I thought no you
didn't you you know i mean it because
that there's not easily equate able
information they didn't turn one you
don't know the exact numbers of the
torrents to yeah i mean at least a whole
other scenario like you it's 2012 and
unless you have distribution in place
you have some sort of
backing and really great name talent and
some form pre-sales if you can get them
there's no reason the world you should
be making a movie a feature independent
film for over probably a hundred
thousand dollars but much less 250 or
500 thousand a lot of you come an idiot
because it going to really damn hard to
make that back i know people my own
backyard talented talented people really
telling more talented than I i would say
gray film cancel can't you know it's
going to be very difficult to ever make
the money back and then and i think that
that's a problem I think that if you're
cagey about the work but cagey about
release in anything cagey about
releasing clips k ji ba you know you
have just being so protective overly
protective maybe is that better were
like you can't be so you want to be
protective of your rights for sure and
if you sign contrasting we all make sure
that you can like that you know if
drought if I have signed that contract
and I haven't received a check from
dropped us yet so there would be legal
action and it would be problems I have
signed some rights away and I've won you
know but in terms of getting the workout
in terms of where most of us are coming
from this day and age and you know and
the fact of the matter that no matter
how much Hollywood tries to litigate
some things technology all these winds
changing you'll progress that you can't
stop I mean it's all the political
things that we're trying to subvert in
this country all of the things we're
transfer technology was and in terms of
piracy you know there's piracy which is
if somebody went and took my DVD of
driven replicated themselves and sold it
from their own website they have just
stole my property and they're selling it
in it's an illegal act if somebody
bought my DVD and then loved it so much
that they want to share with world
they've shared some digital files and I
i see a direct i see a very important
distinction I don't that I see one
that's direct malice I see one that is I
don't know what I described but I don't
think its malice and i think that
there's a problem in this thing's and I
think that too many folks come down on
the side of
like its malice and everyone's out to
get them and I think well probably not
because I mean if you're really
realistic about your situation like iOS
I hope I am and even after doing these
things most people don't know or care
who i am i am just some guy that lives
in idaho that makes foams that most
people don't know they don't work they
don't know anything about me so i'm not
going to be cagey about what I do
because I'd like more people to know
about my work and what I do yeah so I
don't that helps yeah absolutely I guess
I just want to come full circle Gregory
it you know we don't want to continue to
take up too much time we want to wrap it
up here but at the same time any final
thoughts final words on what we're doing
with our goodbyes promise release you
know we're returning to you as a little
bit of a mentor hear me any any
suggestions any advice you know just
just you know obviously this is the
first day but we only a minute we have
no idea where this is going we have like
10 people that have supported this so
far so but just people just give us just
give us your thoughts um well like I
said I can I think it's a really cool
and interesting idea I'm seeing somebody
to use a crowd funding site for this
purpose before I think your price point
is perfect you know it's not you know I
know that there's been arguments against
like we can't price it too low because
then people to find it has no value Oh
reality check most people think that
independent films have no value yeah I
mean let's just be honest thing unless
you give them a reason for a tad value
and I feel like you know I watched your
video on there and then and i paid my to
box so you can watch the movie but i
think that you know you thought all the
things you say in there all the things
you're talking about and also frankly
some of the reviews and some of the
reactions that you are not from the film
you know i think they speak volumes
already you know and in the end I mean
the only thing that I can offer is just
or i can offer anything but
I would just say to you personally is
that you made something you've seen it
all the way through and I put it out in
your doing an interesting way is it
going to be the end-all probably not you
know it's like the next day you're not
to get up and do the same stuff you've
been doing it for the last decade and I
know that you both are used to that you
do it well and I think it just it's just
knowing that that stuff is almost free a
little bit to know that that stuff
doesn't relate and even if you get those
nice little bumps which I hope that we
all do hope that we get those nice
little bumps like our career get the
little bump here and there our
pocketbooks get a little bump here and
there but i'll tell you that just by
simply doing it but even all the things
you've done in the last couple years
with show and now I've seen the film
through now putting it out in a way that
you seems it makes total sense to me I
think is you know a fresh twist on you
know what's been going on with the with
distribution yeah you've set yourself up
for something I don't know what it is
you don't know what it is but you know
you've done so much work that's leading
you somewhere and if you can feel good
and happy about made the biggest thing
is like if you can look down line door
we made a great film and we feel really
proud of how we put it out and you know
maybe we made 1,500 bucks or maybe we
made fifteen thousand one hundred fifty
thousand you know it's taken us
somewhere like we've not we've moved the
needle a little bit and it's all of them
sometimes you move it a lot and
sometimes it just stays there for a
while and it's just all about you know
just ways way before noon no well and I
that's the thing is like everybody is
like oh let me find the new amazing
knowledge that will help me just there
is none you have to work and you have to
work really hard and when unfortunately
you know for people like us when I'm
assuming that you're not independently
wealthy either you know you just have to
sort of slog along and create gift fully
into
you know like I have friends who work in
highwood there was a couple of years and
like little envious of that and I just
realizing what what do I wanted I like
controlling everything that I do I like
being able to say this is what I'm going
to do this project you know me I'm doing
Bloodsworth this next you know I'm doing
a bunch of shooting on this next month
and on bloods written and I'm taking
three days I'm going to Pendleton Oregon
which is about three and half hours wait
for me because it's amazing hundred plus
year old rodeo western event but I love
I'm doing a little short document around
that yeah it put me up and I'm just
doing here so I wanted to do a film
about that you know I just get to pick
up and go and do don't want that life or
do we want this other life there's a
little more you know it's funny because
like I know that most people the
infinite from world or making audition
tapes for the big show and there's
something cool about the big show but I
look at the big show and i love that
make sure i love the movie i'm like i've
seen the avengers i've seen every yeah
ridiculous you a huge blockbuster thing
because they're fun do I make that kind
of movie I haven't yet and I don't know
if it's really in my realm of style and
thinking to do so it's not my thing I
don't know you know I might have so but
I'm not happy with where I'm at yeah
could I do it better made for 1 i'm sure
but that's you know moving the needle
okay okay yeah you're awesome gregory
and you know we encourage everyone who's
who's watched or listened to this this
far please please take time out check
out person of interest you know
certainly check out jens pulver driven
you know it it pulls on the harsh
strings its raw real life it's just
great storytelling yeah and even if
you're not an MMA fan i think what you
said it'll you'll appreciate the the
human-interest part of it as well and
this is rise and the different dips he
took and they will also provide links to
those films
the video yeah you know like thank you
so much thank you doing it just to do
just keep on minute so it's always great
every now and then we kind of just look
out and see what's going on over there
night iOS you see what their veins up to
and just and just sort of you know feed
off that feed off the energy that you
put into what you do well I do the same
with you guys said thanks very much
thank you and also slightly envious we'd
love to be able to live somewhere maybe
a little more remote where you are and
just like you said just having sort of
more control over over time because
really I think that's a lot of times
what it comes down to yes that control
of time and and your actions during that
time yeah it's true helps yeah